this is the most powerful object in the
universe the biggest spinning magnet to
ever exist
it's the cosmic equivalent of a great
white shark but it wouldn't eat you it
would just turn all your atoms to dust
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a magnetar entered our solar
system
[Music]
if you thought neutron stars were big
and scary well you haven't heard of
they're more powerful stellar cousins
yet like neutron stars magnet ours are
leftovers from supernova explosions
they're just packed with a lot more
matter their density is so high that a
single teaspoon of a magnetar could
weigh in at a billion tons there are
also the most magnetic stars we know
about we use a unit called a Gauss to
measure the strength of a magnetic field
Earth's magnetic field is only about 0.6
Gauss the magnetic field of a magnetar
can be as strong as one quadrillion
Gauss how long would it take a stellar
monster like that to rip our planet
apart it wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world if a magnetar was sitting
quietly in our galactic neighborhood but
if it decided to stop minding its own
business there are two ways a magnetar
could end all life on earth together
with the planet itself
it could get too close to the planet
you'd start to feel its presence when it
was about halfway between the moon and
the earth at that distance a magnetar
would erase the information off all your
credit cards magnetic strips whatever
you do try not to get closer than 1000
kilometers from a cosmic invader because
if you did your atoms would get
stretched out of shape your bioelectric
field would get scrambled disintegrating
your molecular structure and your body
would just disappear alternatively a
magnetar could destroy us from much much
further away as if being the biggest
spinning magnets in the universe isn't
enough magnet ours can also be affected
by something called star quakes the star
quakes happen when a star's crust cracks
letting massive amounts of radiation out
into space this blast of radiation could
compress the Earth's magnetic field and
partially ionized the Earth's atmosphere
even from 50,000 light-years away we
know this because we've already come a
little too close on that least one
occasion
in 2004 gamma radiation from a magnetar
reached our planet from outside our
Milky Way galaxy in just one-fifth of a
second it released more energy that our
Sun has released over the last 250,000
years
move that magnetar and it's stark wake
up to 10,000 light years away and things
would get much worse
first it would destroy our ozone plan
then it would wipe clean most of the
planet's surface along with all life as
we know it the truly scary part of this
is that we wouldn't even know the
magnetar was heading towards us it would
be a blink in your gun scenario I won't
lie to you
there are magnetized close enough that
if one had a violent starquake right now
we'd all get wiped out very fast when
scientists began their search for these
interstellar monsters 40 years ago they
didn't realize how many of them exist
out there you might find some comfort in
the fact that most magnet ours don't
make it much past their ten thousandth
birthday their short lifespan ends with
them becoming neutron stars still dense
and still magnetic but not nearly as
dangerous as a magnetar but if one of
them came near our solar system well
that would be a story for another what
if
you